à nous faire une interview dernier coup
vers les chevaux de tête
dernier coup de tête et à 30 secondes de
la tête contre le mur vers les coups de
coeur je pense que j'aime tout le temps
je tombe raide dingue de plein de choses
toujours plus ses coups de poing coups
de poing lycée qui est venu hier matin
chez mon poids je les athées dans les
coups de foudre
elle a tout à l'heure il ya un mec est
passée la maca jambes je me perds tu
l'as fait un trip vient des coups de fil
avec stallone tiennent deux minutes
avant l'indicateur est tous ses
dimanches mans maintenant vous arrêtez
d'avoir peur
l'un des coudes rouge bat aussi elle a
beaucoup de soleil jean-louis je prends
le soleil ne bronze pas j'ai un jour
pour aller faire des photos de nu d'adam
lui la mère de mes enfants
on est parti très très long à l'île
maurice où ça bronze paraît-il j'étais
comme ça les coups de soleil
eh bien je n'osais pas donc on a fait
tous max factor avec blues envie cela
tout le temps forcément
dans les coudre a longtemps voilà à
gagny sa chanson s'appelle comme un
beaunois et
moi
les maths